Back to a question about the rife and grounding. If your feet are grounded, you
once mentioned the rife frequencies would not dissipate throughout your body as well.
This was discussed primarily with the rife grouting mat as opposed to the earthy grouting mat.
So the any grouting mat is the same thing. It's just a conductor of electricity back to your house ground.
So the idea that I've always said, and I know Mike, when Mike was with true rife, he always said,
oh, you should use a grounding sheet and put the grounding sheet on your bed just through the whole full sheet on the bed.
But my argument was, okay, any frequencies that you have coming out of that bulb are going to be attracted to the ground.
Okay, they're going to be attracted to that ground and be carried
basically out through that pan through the wire back to the breaker box back to the ground,
grouting run. That's going to be its first desire. Electricity
desires the easiest mode of transfer. So that's going to be its first desire. So if you're trying to
treat cancer all night and you have the bulb right on your belly and you're sleeping on your back.
So let's pretend if you could see a picture of yourself and your mind, you're laying on your back,
you're laying on your mattress, your mattress has a grounding sheet on it and the bulb is right over your
belly. Well, the frequencies are going to go right through your body and it's going to go to that
grouting mat. It's going to have a less of a chance for it to dissipate. Let's say if you have brain cancer,
it's going to have a less of a chance to dissipate up to your head because it'll be more attracted to the
grouting band. Now the truth be told you're going to still get lots of frequencies that are
hitting your brain and your brain cancer. So it wouldn't be too concerned about it. But just to be
safe, I always said only use the grounding mattress cover that you put under your mattress
on the lower half of your bed. So it's like at your lower waist, your buttocks and down.
Therefore, because not everybody sleeps on their back, all they love holding the bulb on their chest,
right? You the bulb falls to your side, you roll to your side. For me, my bulb was always on my side.
If my bulb was on my side, basically laid right on the mattress and there was a grounding mat right
there, I would lose a percentage of the frequencies right through the ground. And they would have less
of an impact on me. Well, if I have cancer or any disease and I want to be using a rife, I want
the frequencies to go through me and hit that site as much as possible. Well, I also wanted to be
want to be grounded. Well, yeah. So personally, I don't use a grounding mat when I'm sleeping.
And also, I know he's a grody bed at all. And I did in the past have a grody bed
in the winter. I used to have one of my chair at work that I sat on. I don't anymore.
Personally, I get outside a lot. Yes, in the winter, I don't go outside barefoot. So that's why I used
a grody bed on my chair during the winter time. But in the summer, I'm outside all the time and I'm
barefoot all the time. So I don't think I have any issue with, you know, too much positively charged
ions on my body in the summertime, which are probably more of a problem. And I would benefit from
using either a bat on my bed, or like a grounding sheet on my bed, but I'd use it on the lower half
of my bed or a grounding sheet or a grounded pad on my chair. So any one of those things are good.
But just do it on the, if you're doing it on your bed, just do it on the lower half of your bed.